I heard she was in a London gang I heard
her brother and sister ran off together
I heard she got thrown out of her
British College for drug use
[Music]
hey aren't you that transfer student
didn't you get cotton oh no that's not
me
[Music]
7ij
[Music]
how is this happening
[Music]
I'm so sorry oh my god I'm such an idiot
I'm so sorry you let's work in too much
weight it's a bridge hey hey where have
you been I've been texting you yeah I
know I've just been busy
is everything okay yeah you think you
can tell us you know I'm just I'm just
really over being gossiped about I just
want to get along with people here yeah
Saxe it'll be okay though it happened to
me too
people don't know you so you're an easy
target and they like to talk but I
promise everybody is gonna get bored
soon yeah no this should happen to me
all the time in high school my dad moved
abroad for work and people started this
rumor that he had a secret it was so
weird
Oh apparently I dealt crack I was 14 I
worked in a fetish club at 16 not even
legal
I ain't my swing on the womb I believe
that but seriously though just like I
promised that this will all pass and we
know that none of these things are true
obvious yeah that's it no there's no
truth this is Oh [ __ ] you won't get
a drink a scheduling
[Music]
[Music]